>>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAID
THIS WEEK THAT EUROPE FACED A
POSSIBLE, QUOTE, RADIATION
DISASTER WHEN THE RUSSIAN
OCCUPIED NUCLEAR PLANT IN
ZAPORIZHZHIA WAS DISCONNECTED
FROM THE POWER PLANT.
IT'S SINCE BEEN RECONNECTED, BUT
FEARS ARE MOUNTING OF CONTINUED
ATTACKS IN THAT RENAL AND
COMPLEX.
MEANWHILE, THE STATE DEPARTMENT
SAID WEDNESDAY THE U.S. HAD SENT
ITS RESPONSE TO THE EUROPEAN
UNION'S LATEST PROPOSAL TO TRY
TO SAVE THAT DEAL.
THEY CONFIRMED THEY WERE
REVIEWING WASHINGTON'S RESPONSE
NOW.
LET'S SPEAK TO THE FORMER U.N.
SECRETARY AND ONE OF THE
ARCHITECTS OF THE ORIGINAL IRAN
DEAL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
THIS MORNING.
>> THANK YOU, JIM.
>> I SPOKE TO JOHN KIRBY A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
HE SAID THE U.S., IRAN, AND ITS
PARTNERS ARE INDEED CLOSER TO A
DEAL TODAY THAN THEY WERE A WEEK
OR TWO AGO.
IS THAT YOUR VIEW?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT A DEAL CAN
BE RESUR RECOLLECTED HERE?
>> I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE ODDS
ARE.
THEY MAY STILL BE 50/50.
BUT THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY VIEW
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE LOST
BASICALLY FIVE YEARS SINCE THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, FIVE
VALUABLE YEARS I MIGHT SAY,
MAINLY DUE TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
VERY UNWISE DECISION TO LEAVE
THE DEAL IN 2018, THAT EVEN AT
THIS TIME, WE AND OUR FRIENDS
AND PARTNERS IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
I BELIEVE, WOULD BE FAR BETTER
OFF GETTING BACK INTO THE
AGREEMENT.
IN FACT, IF I COULD JUST ADD TO
THAT BRIEFLY, I WOULD SAY THAT,
FIRST, IN TERMS OF THE NUCLEAR
RESTRICTIONS, IT'S CLEAR THAT
THE LOST TIME HAS BEEN USED
EFFECTIVELY BY IRAN TO INCREASE
THEIR NUCLEAR CAPACITY, BUT WE
ALSO SHOULD REMEMBER THAT THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
RESTRICTION WAS THE ONE TO A
SMALL AMOUNT OF VERY LOW AND
RICH URANIUM.
AND EVEN MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE
NUCLEAR RESTRICTIONS ARE THE
EXTRAORDINARY VERIFICATION
MEASURES, THE TOOLS WE'VE PUT IN
THE HANDS OF THE INTERNATIONAL
INSPECTORS, GETTING THOSE BACK
IN PLACE, SOME OF WHICH GO
FOREVER IN MY VIEW IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF GETTING BACK
INTO THE AGREEMENT.
>> THEY DESCRIBED THE
NEGOTIATIONS AS VERIFY BUT
VERIFY TD.
I WONDER, THEY HAVE AMASSED MANY
KILOGRAMS OF RICH URANIUM.
HOW RELIABLY WOULD IRAN'S
BREAKOUT PERIOD TO A NEW WEAPON
WILL LENGTHENED?
>> ACTUALLY, JIM, THEY'VE NOW
ACCUMULATED TONS OF ENRICHED
URANIUM, INCLUDING URANIUM
ENRICHED TO AS MUCH AS 60%,
WHICH IS VERY, VERY CLOSE TO
GETTING TO THE WEAPON GRADE
MATERIAL THAT ONE WOULD NEED.
IN TERMS OF THE BREAKOUT TIME,
DEFINED NARROWLY AS THE TIME IT
WOULD TAKE TO BRING TOGETHER
GOING ALL OUT THE MATERIAL FOR A
NUCLEAR WEAPON, THE DEAL HAD
THAT AT A YEAR OR MORE.
NOW, WE ARE DOWN TO WEEKS.
A RESTORE RATION OF THE
AGREEMENT AND FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF COURSE BY IRAN
WOULD PUT THAT BACK UP TO LET'S
JUST SAY MANY, MANY MONTHS,
WHICH WOULD BE AN ENORMOUS
IMPROVEMENT.
>> OKAY.
AS YOU KNOW, IRAN HAS MANY OTHER
WAYS OF EXERTING AGGRESSION ON
ITS PARTNERS AROUND THE WORLD.
WE'VE SEEN DETAILS ABOUT A PLOT
TO ASSASSINATE JOHN BOLTAGE IN
JUST RECENT MONTHS.
WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER ABOUT THOSE
WHO SAY THIS WILL GIVE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF SANCTION RELIEF TO
A STATE TERRORIST?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THAT WAS THE
SAME ARGUMENT THAT WAS USED IN
2015, AND THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE
IS DOES ONE OR DOES ONE NOT --
OF COURSE, PRESIDENT TO BAM THAT
MA DECIDED TO MOVE FORWARD --
REACH AN AGREEMENT ON THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE ADDITIONAL RESOURCE SNS
NOW, IN THE MEANTIME, THE
SO-CALLED MAXIMUM PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
PUT IN PLACE WITHDRAWING FROM
THE DEAL HAD NO MATERIAL EFFECT
ON THEIR REGIONAL ADVENTURES.
IN FACT, I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY I THE REGIONAL FEARS
INTENSIFIED.
FUNDING DOES NOT SEEM TO BE THE
KEY VARIABLE IN TERMS OF THEIR
DOING REGIONAL MISCHIEF.
SO THEY DO HAVE A LOT OF
ECONOMIC NEEDS, AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE, THEIR ECONOMIC
CONSTRAINTS RIGHT NOW ARE NOT
SIMPLY DUE TO THE SANCTIONS FROM
THE UNITED STATES FOR EXAMPLE,
BUT ALSO DUE TO ISSUES LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DROUGHT,
RESULT IN DROUGHT, WHICH ARE
AFFECTING THEM QUITE BADLY.
>> RUSSIA OF COURSE WAS A
CRUCIAL PLAYER IN THE 2015 DEAL
INCLUDING TAKING THE BULK OF
THAT HIGHLY ENRICHED URANIUM OUT
OF THE COUNTRY.
CAN OTHER PARTNERS, PARTICULARLY
THE UK AND FRANCE WHO HAVE
WIDELY DEVELOPED NUCLEAR
PROGRAMS PICK UP THAT SLACK AND
TAKE THIS ENRICHED URANIUM OUT
OF IRAN?
>> LET ME JUST EMPHASIZE THAT IN
2015, 2016 WITH THE AGREEMENT,
IRAN DID NOT HAVE HIGH ENRICHED
URANIUM.
IT HAS IT NOW BECAUSE OF TRUMP'S
DECISION IN 2018.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT THAT
RUSSIA WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN BEING
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE AGREEMENT,
TAKING ALL OF THAT LOW ENRICHED
URANIUM OUT OF RUSSIA AND IN
ADDITION SOME SCRAP THAT WAS
DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH.
IF RUSSIA NOW DECIDES NOT TO
COOPERATE IN THAT WAY, THEN I
THINK IT WOULD HAVE TO COME TO
FRANCE AND THE UK IN PARTICULAR
WHO HAVE LARGE NUCLEAR
ESTABLISHMENTS TO PICK UP THAT
ROLE.
WHETHER RUSSIA WOULD COOPERATE
OR NOT IS UNCLEAR.
FIRST OF ALL, I WOULD NOTE THAT
IN 2015, WHEN WE REACHED THE
AGREEMENT, WE ALREADY HAD A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME WITH RUSSIA
BECAUSE THEY HAD GONE INTO
CRIMEA FOR EXAMPLE IN 2014
ALREADY, AND BY 2016 WHEN THE
DEAL WAS IMPLEMENTED, THEY HAD
STARTED MILITARY ACTION IN
SYRIA.
SO WE HAD A VERY DIFFICULT TIME,
BUT RUSSIA NEVERTHELESS
COOPERATED.
TODAY, ANOTHER UNFORTUNATE
CONSEQUENCE OF THE 2018 DECISION
WAS TO PUSH IRAN MORE INTO THE
ARMS IF YOU LIKE OF BOTH RUSSIA
AND CHINA.